[Music]
so john there is a ship adrift
that has been abandoned
that has 438
million dollars in total value of goods
it's on fire
and it's and so the the crew abandoned
ship
massive
freighter
and it's full
of volkswagens porsches audis bentleys
and lamborghinis
and it's burning
and drifting through the ocean with no
one on it they all got off and said
peace out i've had a lot of professional
whoopsie-doos in my career dave i can
honestly say
oops
wow
wow the guy the guy the guy that was
having a smoke break next to one of
those cars
and it just went up on him and he went
oh captain that's right captain we gotta
whoops
but the two guys were like hey you won't
throw that over that thing and
i dare you i dare you 100 like this is
um that's unbelievable the vehicles
alone are worth over 155 million
according to one consultant's estimate
now yeah we need to get a consultant to
estimate these um there's a dadgum
manifest there's a list of exactly
what's on there you don't really need to
estimate them you can just add up the
value it's like you should not you
should know what's on there but anyway
what a heartbreaking mess
good grief you said they got two tugs
with firefighting equipment expected to
arrive today
monday morning which was yesterday for
most people no that's today
yeah i'm so confused start spraying
water
spray water
oh it's awful
you know and i gotta tell you guys every
there's there's a certain number of guys
that i'm trying to they're trying to
figure out how they can get could i swim
out here that's how i can get one of
those lamborghinis off of that boat okay
i see what it says so so volkswagen's
going to lose 155 million
in the other car volkswagen's insurance
company sure
yeah and then the other ones will lose
about 250 million dollars with the cars
wow
a lot of cars
folks who i can suppose spokesman
declined to comment because he can't
breathe so
our our word of caution to america if
you happen to be on craigslist in a few
months and uh
someone offers you a great deal on
lamborghini's lamborghini's on fire
hot prices this is a hot price
it's
it will melt you
five thousand dollars you're probably
going to want to pass
no attention to the fact that tires are
burned go back to the corolla section
and let the lamborghini section go
oh how horrible we're laughing but i
just gotta
this breaks my heart i don't know what
else you can do i don't know what you do
you just laugh